great so um thank you for sticking
around for the very last uh talk of the
week here i'm happy to uh present ra
rahul who will be telling us more about
kernel methods in causal in inference
yeah thank you chris so the title for
today is kernel methods for long-term
causal inference my name is rahul i'm a
research fellow here at simons and i'm
also a phd at mit
motivation for this project is project
star which stands for the tennessee
student teacher achievement ratio
experiment
in which a cohort of kindergarteners in
1985 were randomly assigned to either
small or regular class sizes
we see in the picture one of the small
class sizes which was 13 to 17 students
and that's smaller than what was
considered regular in the state of
tennessee at the time
this was one of the large labor market
interventions we have with randomization
and involved about 11 600 students and
teachers
with randomization we have
identification and we asked we can ask
what were the effects so kruger in 1999
studied the effects in the duration of
the experiment it was four years it
followed these kindergartners through
third grade
and in the figure we're looking at
counter factual distributions of test
scores so the dashed line is the counter
factual distribution of test scores if
all the students were assigned to the
regular class size but the filled line
is the counter factual distribution of
test scores if they're all assigned to
small classes we can see it's pushed out
a little bit to the right
roughly a decade later chatty and
co-authors took this experimental data
set which was remember only four years
of data and merge it with administrative
data
which means tax returns and things like
that to follow those kindergartners
after they've reached the age of 27 and
we can look at these medium term
variables like college quality and maybe
earnings at 27.
in this figure again we're looking at
counter factual distributions
this time we're looking at distributions
of college quality
and the blue curve is the counter
factual distribution of college quality
and the thought experiment which all the
students were assigned to the regular
class size the green curve is the
counter factual distribution if they're
all assigned to the small class size and
these just need to be normalized
near the end of the paper the authors
write
we conclude by using our empirical
estimates to provide rough calculations
of the benefits of various policy
interventions
these cost-benefit calculations rely on
several strong assumptions
we assume that the percentage gain in
earnings observed at age 27 remains
constant over the life cycle
and i think there are several
interesting ideas in these few sentences
one idea is that if we really want to do
a cost benefit analysis of project star
we do we need to extrapolate beyond even
what we get by merging with
administrative data
we need to extrapolate from earnings at
27 all the way up to perhaps earnings at
the age of retirement at 65.
another interesting idea is that we need
assumptions to do that extrapolation and
this assumption this very strong one is
maybe one we're uncomfortable with
what i want to take away from the
discussion of project star is that
experimental data it's very expensive to
collect and therefore typically short
term so project star only lasted four
years and it cost the state of tennessee
12 million dollars
even if we have special sworn status and
can merge our experimental data sets
with administrative ones
still that only takes us to the medium
term up to age 27 but that's not quite
everything we want to learn because cost
benefit analysis depends on the long
term
we might be interested in asking which
social policies pay for themselves
maybe project scar costs 12 million
dollars with those students when not
become high earners and high taxpayers
and maybe the state of tennessee made
back much more than 12 million
there's also this discomfort with the
constant effect over time assumption and
indeed empirically we see that test
score effects fade over time so maybe
earnings effects fade over time too
and a big question is that i'll try to
address today what can we say about
long-term effects in a principled but
also ideally flexible way
the main idea is that to think about the
long-term effects we're going to combine
data from two data sets
first an experimental data set that's
like the project star data set as merged
with administrative data that has the
treatment and these medium term
variables
and second an observational data set
that has medium term variables and
long-term ones this is something like an
appendix table that this paper has which
has correlations between earnings at 27
and earnings later on
in this work i'll propose kernel
estimators that have closed form
solutions and that come with strong
finite sample guarantees
for treatment effects i'll prove
long-term treatment effects i should say
i'll prove root n consistency finite
sample gaussian approximation and
semi-parametric efficiency
for long-term dose responses i'll prove
uniform consistency with finite sample
rates
and for long-term counterfactual
distribution i'll prove finite sample
can
convergence in a certain norm which
implies convergence and distribution
overall my goal in this project is to
provide a unified framework for flexible
estimation of these long-term causal
parameters
the key assumption i'll make today is
that a certain conditional distribution
is smooth and a certain regression is
smooth in the paper i'll further
characterize an idea of multiple
spectral robustness in the
semi-parametrics which is another take
on double sparsely robustness which has
become quite popular in semi-parametrics
in this work i build on many that came
before
first and foremost on the long
literature of statistical surrogates
which refers to when you have an
experiment and they're just these
short-term outcomes which are kind of
surrogates for the long-term variables
we really care about there's a long
history
in statistics and biostatistics that's
recently been revived which different
authors propose different identifying
assumptions
and different takes on the problem
i'll also build on existing
semi-parametric theory in particular
principles from d-bias machine learning
which distill
rate conditions which are sufficient for
the good properties we'd like
a big step in this direction is from
chenin swallower who characterized the
multiply robust moment function
an important paper to mention is the
bataccidal paper in which the authors
prove these good properties for
estimators that impose linearity and
separability and one thing i'm going to
try to do in this paper is relax those
kinds of
aspects because strictly speaking they
aren't required for identification
in terms of nonparametrics again i'll
build on papers that came before an
important one here is das nui vela 2003
which is about structural functions in
the presence of sample selection a
little later on we'll see the connection
to the sample selection problem
i'll also build on previous work that
provides uniform analysis for causal
kernel methods but for much simpler
problems like dose responses and
heterogeneous treatment effects in just
the usual treatment effects setting
the key algorithmic technique is going
to be something called a sequential mean
embedding and that'll feature
prominently in both the non-parametrics
and in the semi-parametrics and we'll
walk through that together
overall in this work the estimators and
their guarantees are new
so let's return to what is the data
setting
well we have an experimental data set
this is like the one in the main text of
the jedidol paper where it's the project
star data set with individuals
specifically we see their demographics
their class size and also their earnings
at 27. we do not get to see their
earnings thereafter for example their
earnings at 65.
meanwhile we have another data set
perhaps using our special sworn status
which is observational so it's students
who did not take part in project star
and for them we have their demographics
their earnings at 27 and their earnings
at 65
and we're interested in reasoning about
what was the effect of class size on
earnings at 65
even though we have one data set in
which we're missing earnings at 65 and
another in which we're missing class
size
here on i'm going to use
the language of covariates treatments
surrogates and outcomes instead so we
have an experimental data set with
covariate x treatment d and surrogate m
but we're missing the outcome y and we
have another data set where we have the
covert x the circuit m the outcome y but
we're missing the treatment d
and we're interested in reasoning about
the effect of the treatment on the
outcome
the first step is to define a fused data
set by which i mean let's take the rows
from the experimental data set and
concatenate them with the rows from the
observational data set
then let's take a look at what happens
to the columns
well the covariate columns are exactly
as before because we see covariates in
both data sets
the treatment column is a bit
interesting because we do see treatments
for the experimental group but then we
have n a's in the observational group
and i'll follow the convention of
overriding those n a's as zeros
we have the surrogate columns which are
as before
the outcome column is interesting again
because there are nas for the
experimental group but we have real
values for the observational group
so in the fuse data set we get to see
covariates we get to see this fused
treatment variable d prime which is
sometimes nas
we see the surrogate columns and we see
these
fused outcomes which i'll call y prime
written this way i think it becomes
quite clear the connection to classic
sample selection problems in the spirit
of reuben 76 and hackman 79.
for identification i'm going to quote an
existing result from atheidal and my
focus will instead be on estimation and
inference
so
here's here are some identifying
assumptions there are three categories
of them
first of all sutfa kind of ruling out
network effects
next assumptions about the treatment
mechanism and we only see the treatment
in the experimental sample so these
assumptions are all conditional one
being in the experimental sample
we have that treatment is confounded
that is conditional and covariance it's
as good as randomly assigned
we have surrogacy which is arguably the
strongest assumption conditional on
covariates and surrogates treatments
independent of outcome
and then we have an
overlap condition
next we have assumptions about the
selection mechanism the first of which
is precisely rubin's missing at random
assumption that conditional on
covariates selection is as good as
randomly assigned
next we have comparability and finally
selection overlap
for today let's consider the causal
parameter i'll call theta naught with
argument little d and that's the mean
potential outcome in the thought
experiment in which we overwrite the
treatment to be
the value little d
atheidal proved that under the stated
assumptions this causal parameter can be
expressed as the very interesting double
integral we see on the slide
which has several objects in it it has
gamma naught which is a function
it has a conditional distribution and it
has a marginal distribution
now where do these come from well the
conditional distribution is from the
experimental sample where we do get to
see surrogates and treatments
the the function is a regression that we
get from the observational sample where
we do get to see the outcome and we do
get to see the surrogates
and finally the marginal distribution
can be from both of these samples
i want to point out the sense in which
in this expression everything's very
linked
so in that final integral with the
marginal distribution it's with respect
to x which appears in both the function
gamma naught and in the conditional
distribution
which we're using to integrate gamma
naught so it's very non-separable and
perhaps not obvious how one might be
able to estimate
there are also a few different
perspectives we can take on what this
integral equation really means
if we take treatment to be binary
then on the left hand side we have a
scalar
which is like a treatment effect
and on the right hand side we see a
nonlinear functional which quite
resembles robin's g formula
another point of view we might take is
if treatment is continuous so instead of
they're just being regular or small
class sizes there's really the number of
students who are in your class
in such case on the left hand side we
have a function and on the right hand
side we're integrating this function
this regression according to a
conditional and then a marginal
distribution
the idea of integrating out
arguments of a regression is sometimes
called a partial mean in econometrics
um
and and here we have a sequential
partial mean
ah yes please
very very very common sorry
you mentioned it looks like the g
formula it also looks like the mediation
formula right
because because of the the you know
doctorate of the different uh treatments
except that this is just the indicator
of the domain here right absolutely
and uh in another work i argue that
mediation analysis dynamic treatment
effects and this long-term effect
problem all are the same class of
nonlinear functions
here
when i opened i have these figures which
were counterfactual distributions in
such case on the left hand side the
causal parameter is a distribution which
is indexed by a treatment value little d
which could be discrete or continuous
and so on the right hand side instead of
integrating a function we're integrating
a distribution gamma naught in such case
instead of being a partial mean it's
like having a partial distribution or
pushed even further a sequential partial
distribution
the rest of the presentation i'll focus
on the dose response perspective but in
the paper i'll cover all three
and i'll also extend analysis to
different causal parameters such as for
subpopulations like just the students
who are in the experimental sample like
in project star
and also alternative populations what if
project star didn't take place in
tennessee but rather here in california
for estimation i'm going to bring in the
technology of the rkhs
in particular i'm going to assume that
this function gamma naught is in an rkhs
that is a tensor product
so what do i mean by that
it's like i choose features for
selection 5g features for covariates phi
x and features for the surrogates phi m
and then takes the take the tensor
product of those to define the features
i'm interested in for the function gamma
naught
formally the property md i'm using here
is that if you take the product of three
kernels you get a new kernel
with this construction i'm able to
express the cause parameter which is an
interesting and complicated double
integral in a very concise way
if we believe that gamma naught is in
that rkhs
then the causal parameter can be
expressed as the inner product of c
it's an inner product between the
regression gamma naught and something
that's quite interesting this mu3
which encodes sequentially both of those
distributions
first of all we encode the conditional
distribution by writing a conditional
mean embedding essentially we're
re-weighting the surrogate features by
the conditional distribution and that's
the way that we're going to embed it
next we need to embed the marginal
distribution
and because these two conditional
distributions involve x we need to first
take
the outer product with features of x
before doing that embedding
well together then we're getting gamma
naught from the observational sample
and we're going to multiply it with this
sequential embedding which involves
a conditional distribution from the
experimental sample
and then a marginal distribution which
could be from both
this is a bit of an abstract slide but
it actually gives us the blueprint for
estimation
because it tells us if you just do a
non-parametric regression like a kernel
ridge regression that'll give you gamma
naught
and then how do we get mu3 well first
you need to do 1 which is something like
a generalized regression instead of
having a scalar outcome we have features
of surrogates as the outcome
so that's a generalized kernel rate
regression as well
next we need to do just some kind of
empirical averaging right it's a
marginal distribution and finally we
take the product and we're done
indeed this algorithm i'm describing
verbally will have a closed form
solution by the usual representer
theorems
and it's pretty simple to describe
it's just three steps
first of all we'll calculate our
empirical kernel matrices which are n by
n
second of all we make we'll make these
vectors which are of length n
which are
essentially
the way that we're doing that
generalized kernel retrogression for the
conditional distribution we can see how
this is really like a generalized kernel
ridge regression of features of targets
that's the features of m on the other
variables
and it has a ridge regression
regularization that's what i'm going to
call lambda experimental because this is
using observations from the experimental
sample
and then in the next step we see that
there is a more familiar kernel range
regression of the outcome on variables
that's from
uh the observational sample so i'll call
that regularization parameter lambda
observational
finally we have the marginal
distribution to average over and that's
the averaging we see out front
so stepping back there are two sets of
hyperparameters here there are ridge
regression penalties lambda experimental
lambda observational for which we can
derive theoretical values that balance
bias and variance but also it turns out
that level now cross validation as a
closed form solution because we're doing
ridge kind of regressions here
and so you only have to compute the
estimator once
we're also hyper parameters of the
kernels but for those we have well known
heuristics for gaussian kernel for
example we would use the median
interpoint distance
so what can we prove about this
estimator which we saw in three steps
well recall that this was the causal
parameter we're interested in
and i'll place four assumptions
first some weak regulated conditions on
the original spaces
second some weak regularity conditions
on the rk chesses and then two more
substantial conditions which are really
about smoothness so smoothness of the
conditional distribution and smoothness
of the regression
let's get the regularity conditions out
of the way
well we'll require that the treatment
covariance target spaces are polish and
that's really flexible so these
variables could be reals texts images
there's really a lot of flexibility here
i'll also impose that the outcome is
bounded just to make things shorter
that can be relaxed
for the rkhs's i'll impose that the
kernels are continuous and bounded their
feature maps are measurable and that
certain kernels are characteristic
that just means that these embeddings in
which i'm encoding
the distributions in the rkts
that's an injective mapping so there are
unique rkhs representations
fortunately all these conditions hold
for all the usual kernels used in
practice like the gaussian spine and
sublux kernels
the substantial assumptions i'll place
are about smoothness a smoothness about
the conditional distribution and about
the regression
for the conditional distribution it's
helpful to
reparameterize it as a conditional
expectation operator that's smooth and
i'll call it smoothness parameter c
experimental because this is going to be
estimated with experimental observations
for the regression learn from the
observational sample i'll call it
smoothness parameter c observational
the intuition for these smoothness
parameters before we see more formally
what they mean
they're really approximation error
assumptions that are used to analyze the
bias from the ridge
regularization they're essentially
saying that certain statistical targets
are well approximated by the top
eigenfunctions of the kernel
these are called source conditions both
in statistical learning theory
literature and in econometrics
literature
what i don't understand is the next line
which says that the target is in the
interior of its arch rkhs like if we're
we have a linear
kernel
then i think
like every point is in the interior
uh what is it what do you
elaborate what you mean here yeah thanks
that was uh that is i hear a new
statement and i think this slide will be
uh clarifying what i'm doing
so a special case of an rkhs is the
symbolism and let's consider the solo
space hs
where s is the number of square integral
derivatives and p is the dimension of
the input space
the solo space is an rkhs if and only if
s is greater than p over two and that's
a very familiar condition from
functional analysis
suppose we use that as our rkhs for
estimation
meanwhile the truth what we're trying to
estimate is in the solo space with s
naught degrees of smoothness
then by c i mean the ratio of s naught
over s
so it quantifies the additional
smoothness of the statistical target
relative to the hypothesis space we're
using for estimation
so i was being loose when i said in the
interior it's like it's a little
smoother than it needs to be
in my analysis i'm going to require that
c is greater than 1 which is like saying
that s naught is greater than s is
greater than p over two so it's a
somewhat strong smoothness conditions
um
so i could
similarly characterize what this means
in the context of the gaussian kernel uh
maybe i can show that with it offline
under these stated conditions
and if we calibrate the regularization
of the balanced bias and variance we get
a result like we see on the slide
where n is the sample size c
experimental is the smoothness of the
conditional distribution since the
observational is the smoothness of the
regression
this rate is at best n to the minus the
sixth by setting both of those smoothest
parameters up to two
to interpret the results some more on
the left hand side we have a soup norm
guarantee
which is going to be uniform across all
treatment levels across all classroom
sizes
and that's stronger than a mean squared
error guarantee which is kind of on
average across treatment levels i think
that's important because it encodes
caution if we're going to use results
like these to inform labor market policy
this rate is somewhat slow it's at best
n to the minus the sixth
but
in the result i've put on up on the
slide so far it's using relatively
minimal assumptions one could place
stronger assumptions to get faster rates
and it doesn't directly depend on data
dimension but that's because we are
smooth enough relative to dimension
when it comes to semi-parametrics i'd
also like to point out that it's not too
slow in the sense that
minus the sixth plus minus a third is
minus a half so you get the sense of
where this multiple spectral robustus
idea will will come up
in the paper i provide exact finite
sample rate so results in the form with
probability 1 minus delta the bound and
soup norm is something
to conclude in this work i propose a
family of estimators for long-term
causal inference
that are relatively easy to implement
because they have closed form solutions
i also provide strong finite simple
guarantees for the treatment effects
dose responses and counter factual
distributions
my big picture goal is to provide
something of a bridge between this idea
of long-term cost-benefit analysis
and between kernel methods to answer
questions like which labor market
policies pay for themselves
this work is part of a broader agenda
where the main idea is that causal
inference presents us with very
interesting and challenging integral
equations
while kernel methods provides us with
the techniques to solve them
i love to talk more and here's my email
address
uh are there any questions for our
speaker here
i have i have one um if you go back
one's one slide uh you have these um
penalty
uh terms that show up in the re
regressions
uh these like lambdas here um
i i guess you could you know we don't
know the smoothness you know beforehand
but i assume we could
like
find the best lambdas are using crossfit
or something like that do you guys have
um uh like
theory for that or do you have a sense
of how that might uh work work work out
or change the rates or the rates for the
yeah yeah that's a great question
um
so uh just like leave an outcross
validation as a closed form so does
generalized cross-validation
and that's kind of an old and classic
result
and for certain rkhs's we know that
generalized cross-validation is
asymptotically optimal so it will trade
off bias and variance like it should
um i think a characterization that's
more general for kind of all rk chesses
is an interesting direction to argue
that generalized cross-validation will
kind of work for all rkt tests yeah
that's an interesting direction to go in
awesome
i have one more question but i'd like to
ask if anyone else has a has a question
here
and it'll be mine um my other question
is uh
with like
um with this experiment this uh
tatar
um you know i
i'm wondering if if you happen to know
what they were interested in
investigating with these small classroom
sizes
um because you know the the story that
you
gave of knowing what their you know what
the effect is on their and their
earnings you know at 65
um
that makes sense to me
but i'm kind of thinking like oh well
did the star people have i mean they
don't they did they have the methodology
to do that were they thinking about that
what were they so i guess i wonder if
you know what their
what their goals were and their uh i'd
love to hear more about that yeah so
project star was spearheaded by a former
teacher
and she was particularly interested in
what is her what's the right class size
we should have in our schools in
tennessee
and it was designed to be just for these
four years so it's with some creativity
that we're trying to extrapolate beyond
that
and i think that's kind of
representative of what we often do in
experiments where we have a certain
scope and a certain budget and so we do
something and then after the fact we try
to extrapolate we try to glean something
more than that but the original
intention was really just about the
effect of kindergarten size
natural age
uh yes another question here
uh the surrogate so uh one assumption i
think in the surrogacy is that uh you
don't need that observed confounding
between the trigger and the outcome so
is that like something reasonable for
the star application or the project star
question
should we worry about things that we're
not controlling that are directly
affecting the
medium term and the long term
yeah that's a great question i think
maybe we would need to talk to some
domain experts in education research to
see if they believe the assumption
fortunately if we don't believe the
assumption there are other
identifications uh that we have with
like proximal settings in which case
instead of having kind of regressions
we'll have confounding bridges and
they're kernel methods for those as well
so the general architecture of these
techniques will absolutely go through
so i have a question about the rate you
have here on the slide so i understand
that this is standard in some
communities but not in my community so
uh
so the order depends on the ins
something that you don't know so i
wonder right so how do you use this to
say evaluate the star policy like
if it depends on the instance you play
play some extra assumption what do you
do
yeah that's a great question
so when it comes to semi-parametrics
it's if we're willing to take a stand on
how smooth things are it ends up being
root n so we don't need to
and we can you know estimate and provide
a confidence interval
um
that will have
asymptotically to achieve nominal
coverage and all that
for non-parametrics and the finite
simple i think it's a good question i
think that brings our attention to the
problem of uniform inference
in which case we could provide a uniform
confidence band which has some
interpretation i agree that a result
like this
is perhaps not strong enough for
really making policy recommendations
great are there any more uh questions
here
well if not let's thank the uh
speaker
and i think that concludes the workshop
for this week
so thank you everyone for